one problem 28 four pumps began draining
a 5400 gallon pool
at the same time two pumps began
draining a 4 000 gallon pool assuming
that all of the pumps drain at the same
rate at the same rate how many gallons
are left in the smaller pools on the 4
000 gallon pool when the larger pool is
finished being drained and notice they
didn't tell us how fast the pumps work
so let's just assume that let's say that
each pump drains at x gallons
x gallons per
minute so four pumps will drain at 4x
gallons per minute two pumps will drain
at 2x gallons a minute so how many
minutes does it take to drain the 5400
gallon pool
will be 5400 gallons
i'll just write g's or let's say gallons
divided by
x
gallons or actually 4x because we have
four pumps 4x
gallons
per minute
and what is this equal to if we divide
the numerator and the denominator by
two actually let's just divide by four
four goes into fifty four hundred four
goes into five one time one times four
is four
bring down the one four goes into
fourteen three times three times four is
twelve and we have a twenty four goes
into twenty five times so it goes
thirteen fifty times so this is equal to
over x minutes
to drain
to drain the 5400 gallon pool
now how much has drained out of the 4
000 gallon pool at that point well we're
going to be draining 2x
gallons
gallons per minute and how long are we
going to be doing that for well we're
going to do it until or we're going to
be watching this experiment until this
pool is completely drained we figured
out this is how long it takes to drain
it 1350 over x minutes so if we're going
to be pumping out at 2x gallons per
minute in the smaller pool because we
have two pumps so 2x gallons per minute
times this many minutes times 1350
over x minutes
this is going to tell us how many
gallons have pumped out of the 4 000
gallon pool so the x's cancel out you
have an x in the numerator and x in the
denominator the minutes cancel out so
our answer will be in gallons so it's 2
times 13 50. so what do we get we get
we get 20 what is that 27
gallons
that's how much has been pumped out of
the 4 000
gallon pool right this is how much has
been pumped out 2x times 1350 over x is
2700 that's how much has been pumped out
so but they're asking us how much how
many gallons are left
in the smaller pool so if we started
with 4 000
and we subtract 2700
that's going to be 1300 gallons are left
in the pool
that is choice a
problem 29
use the graph below to answer the
question that follows switch colors
used monotony the graph above shows the
distance d
in miles and the time t in minutes for
six bus routes around a city
which of the following equations best
models a relationship between d and t
for these bus routes
so these are different bus routes it's
almost a line i mean we can kind of do
it in the light color so i don't mess up
the graph but we could see you know i
see a line that looks something
it looks something like that right there
if i had to fit a line into there let's
see which of the following equations
best models a relationship so t is equal
to d what would that look like that line
i'll do it in i'll do this light green
color t is equal to d so when t is equal
to 10 d is equal to 10 when t is equal
to 20 d is equal to 20. t is equal to 30
d is equal to 30. so that's this line
right here
this line right here that doesn't seem
to model these black dots too well so
it's not going to be that answer
let me do another one t is equal to d
plus 10. so if we start at 10
so
when t when d is 0 t will be 10 right
there when d is 10 d will be 20
right d plus 10 20 when it's when d is
20 t will be 30 it's going to look like
this
this is a little it's an improvement but
it still doesn't look that great to me
so let's just you know it's probably not
that t is equal to 2d well 2d
when when you're zero you're at zero
when t is equal to 10 you're going to be
at 20. when t is equal to 20 you're
going to be at 40 so it's going to go
like something like this
it's going to look something
over 40 right here it's going to look
something like this which is close it
seems to have the right slope let's see
look at the last choice so that i'm
guessing the last choice is going to get
us right there t is equal to 2d plus 10.
let me do this in blue because i'm
feeling this is the right answer so we
start at 10 when d is 0 t is 10
and then we go up by 2d or another way
you could think of it when
d is 10
we get 2 times 10 plus 10. we're going
to go to 30.
when d is 20
2 times 20 plus 10 is 50 we're going to
be at 50. so the line looks something
like this
it will look like
it will look like that which is a pretty
good fit of the curve it's definitely
the best out of the four choices so i'll
go with d
next question let's see are there any
questions on this page no next page
next question
see
use the graph below to answer the
question that follows okay they've drawn
us a line they've drawn some points on
the line the graph above represents the
equation wx plus 4y is equal to minus
12. what is the value of w
so they're essentially i mean they gave
us two points so we can easily figure
out we can figure out actually the
equation of this line which might be but
maybe we don't have to go that far so if
we could just write this line and y is
equal to mx
plus b form and maybe if we just figure
out the slope of the line that's b
that'll be enough so they said that the
line is wx plus 4y
is equal to minus 12. if we subtract i
just want to put into the standard mx
plus b form so if we re if we subtract w
x from both sides we get 4y
is equal to minus wx minus 12 and then
divide both sides by 4 you get y is
equal to minus w over 4 x
minus
3.
so this is the equation of the line we
have to figure out what w is this right
here minus w over 4 is the slope of the
line so let's figure out what the slope
is slope is just change in x
slope
is equal to change in x
over sorry
is equal to change in y
change in y over change in x rise over
run how much do you change in y when you
change a certain amount in x so in this
case it's going to be equal to let's
take this as our first point so we take
the y's 2 minus minus 3 2 minus
minus 3
over right that's the change in y
2 minus minus 3 right
and then the second one we use the 2 as
the first point here so i'll use the
minus 4 is the first point to the
denominator minus 4
minus this x value is 0. so the slope
here is equal to 2 minus minus 3. that's
the same thing as 2 plus 3 which is just
5 over
minus 4. so this is the slope so 5 over
minus 4 has to be the same thing as
minus w over 4. so you could say or we
could write minus 5 4
is equal to minus w over 4. you could
pattern match that immediately that w's
got to be equal to five you could also
solve for w but let's just do the
pattern matching that makes it easier